es ist ein jahrelanges verhältnis von
falscher rücksichtnahme ein verhältnis
von lügen und enttäuschungen ein
verhältnis von zu wenig druck und den
fehlenden konsequenzen
es sind wegmarken wie diese die die
deutsche russland politik beschreiben
und die vor allem durch nachsicht
geprägt sind 2011 eröffnet die deutsche
kanzlerin die erste gaspipeline durch
die ostsee nord stream 1
nord stream zwei folgt nur wenige jahre
später es sind diese entscheidungen die
gas zu einer waffe werden lassen einer
waffe die sich heute auch gegen europa
gerichtet und sie wurden getroffen
obwohl man es hätte besser wissen müssen
erst mal hat es jahre hinweg anzeichen
gegeben dass putin durchaus gerade das
gas als politische waffe 0 sie hatte
schon 2006 gegeben als er das erste mal
der ukraine den gashahn zudreht und
insofern muss ich schon sagen das ist
etwas wenn man auf den an den amtseid
denkt schaden vom deutschen volk
abzuwenden
das ist etwas was sie eben gerade nicht
getan hat
angela merkel hat das immer bestritten
auch öffentlich die abhängigkeit
geleugnet in die sie deutschland und
europa gebracht hat
wir wollen uns unter gar keinen
umständen allein von russland abhängig
machen aber russland war schon im kalten
krieg eine quelle von gas und wird es
auch weiter bleiben ohne dass wir in
eine einseitige abhängigkeit
hineingehen es gab einen
innenpolitischen konsens raus aus atom
raus aus der kohle dann bleibt nur gas
übrig verteidigt lars hendrik röller
merkels wirtschaftsberater die alte
politik
dass nahezu alle die amerikaner das
eu-parlament die öffentlichen partner
ein anderes bild von putin und seiner
gaspolitik hatten und haben hat merkel
ignorieren
frau bundeskanzlerin sie schweigen seit
beginn des krieges
denn just dabei hat gerade die politik
deutschlands
während der vergangenen jahre dazu
geführt dass russland heute eine stärke
hat die auf dem monopol des verkaufs von
rohstoffen basiert
kritik an merkel die sich heute als
richtig erweist ich glaube dass es ein
großer schuss überheblichkeit gewesen
und der natürlich auch mit dem
zusammenhängt was die deutschen in den
letzten jahren wieder so hervorragend
einstudiert und gekonnt haben nämlich
das was jemand so schön den moralischen
appell ismus neunte
moralische werte die lesung eigene
interessen geht auch schnell wieder
vergessen werden der verkauf der
deutschen gasspeicher
2015 an gazprom germania wird durch die
regierung merkel ausdrücklich gebilligt
der russische überfall auf die krim war
erst ein jahr her
kanzlerin und wirtschaftsminister hatten
damals keine einwände man brauchte
russland wieder mal deswegen rate ich
dazu dass wir unser verhältnis zu
russland ändern und einfach die
realitäten akzeptieren
ohne eine zusammenarbeit mit russland
werden wer den krieg in syrien nicht
beenden können und hat im wesentlichen
muss und geguckt und wenn russland
irgendwo zerstörte hat man versucht
diese streitpunkte auszuräumen auch zu
ungunsten der ukraine
wie ist also die verantwortung der
ehemaligen kanzlerin welche fehler hat
sie gemacht
nachfolger friedrich merz versucht das
thema wegzuhalten von seiner cdu
schließlich zieht der wie schwer sich
die sozialdemokraten mit dem erbe von
schröder und steinmeier tun ich habe
sehr viel respekt
davor dass der bundespräsident sich so
geäußert hat wie er es in dieser woche
getan hat und ob andere das auch tun das
muss jeder für sich allein entscheiden
jeder für sich allein und nicht als
partei das ist manchem in der cdu zu
wenig
die cdu hat angela merkel als
bundeskanzlerin getragen
selbstverständlich auch wir haben jeden
anlass zur selbstkritik
angela merkel derzeit als privatperson
in italien schweiz eine stellungnahme
sei nicht geplant lässt sie mitteilen
[Musik]